bonsoir jeudi 24 septembre bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 60,18 voici les
titres de cette édition
les dernières mesures annoncées hier par
le gouvernement nous rappelle les
sombres heures du confinement une
période pas seulement négatives ou des
chaînes de solidarité ont pu se créer
notamment pour le personnel des hôpitaux
cet élan se poursuit t-il aujourd'hui
retour d'expérience avec plusieurs
yvelinois la mobilisation de collectif
féministe aujourd'hui devant la cour de
versailles une soixantaine de personnes
s'est rassemblée en soutien à julie
cette adolescente dénoncent des viols
commis par vingt pompiers de paris des
faits requalifiés il ya un an en
atteintes sexuelles en réunion
l'audience en appel de cette décision se
tenait ce matin et depuis le
déconfinement ils pullulent les guêpes
et frelons asiatiques sont beaucoup plus
nombreux cette année conséquence
principalement d'un derniers hivers trop
d'où nous avons suivi une société
spécialisée dans le traitement des nids
de ces insectes
19 repart dans une hausse inquiétante
dans les yvelines un taux d'incidence à
74 un taux de positivité à 7,2 pour cent
et d'après les dernières données
communiquées mardi pour freiner cette
progression partout en france le
ministre de la santé
olivier vers en a fait des annonces si
hier le gouvernement durcit le ton en
ile-de-france désormais deux zones
identifiées une zone d' alerte renforcée
en rouge sur la carte qui concerne paris
et la petite couronne lé département des
yvelines de l'essonne du val d'oise et
de la seine-et-marne sont eux placés en
zone d'alert alors dans les faits pour
paris les hauts-de-seine le val-de-marne
et la seine-saint-denis notamment parmi
les mesures aient les bars devront
fermer dès 22h à partir de lundi les
grands rassemblements limités à 1000
personnes dans l'espace public
interdiction des rassemblements de plus
de 10 personnes enfin à fermeture
prononcé également pour les salles des
fêtes et polyvalente ainsi que pour les
salles de sport et les gymnases à partir
de lundi alors ce qui concerne les
départements de la grande couronne pour
le moment l'interdiction de
rassemblements privés comme les
anniversaires et les mariages depuis de
30 personnes à partir de lundi des
mesures qui seront valables pendant une
durée de 15 jours minimum et qui doivent
faire encore l'objet d'une concertation
avec les préfets ces derniers pourront
prendre d'ailleurs et des mesures
complémentaires si besoin
n'espérons pas tout de même que nous en
arrivions un nouveau confinement même si
c'est une période il faut le reconnaître
qui a eu ses bons côtés de nombreuses
élan de solidarité se sont créés un peu
partout en france et dans les yvelines
dons de nourriture dont deux temps aide
aux courses ou soutien au personnel
soignant
six mois après le début de la crise
sanitaire mélanie poké et marie
pannetrat sont allés voir si cet élan se
poursuit aujourd'hui
comme chaque matin jean christophe vous
dis prépare le repas des 600 élèves du
collège apollinaire de plaisir mais
chaque dimanche les repas sont destinés
à d'autres gourmet le centre hospitalier
de versailles les pompiers de maurepas
et de louveciennes une initiative débuté
en mars est toujours en cours
j'ai des amis qui sont dans la
profession médicale et je trouve que
c'est un peu dommage que ça s'arrête
d'un coup parce que voilà ces gens vous
un vrai confort le plus de possibles et
la brosse de chance que j'ai c'est ma
directrice de collège et les
autorisations de 6000 ont été données
pour que je puisse utiliser vous
toujours pour fabriquer justement c'est
dire pas ce sont 700 repas qui sont
préparées par jean christophe et son
équipe grâce au partenariat de
fournisseurs artisans et grandes
surfaces
en mai dernier les pattes de la
fondation béland à magnanville recevait
deux semblent ou jetable pour son
personnel du matériel créé par des
couturières amateurs du collectif blues
pour l'hôpital une initiative arrêtés
fin juin qui tend aujourd'hui à se
professionnaliser
on a clairement eu pendant de la partie
bénévoles des couturières qui disait
mais non je suis en train de piquer le
boulot à des pouvoirs des couturières
professionnels donc ça ne va pas et la
notion de dire si on va on va monter
quelque chose autour des couturières
professionnels à l'origine c'est une
demande de bénévoles dans lequel il ya
aussi des propos aujourd'hui organisés
en tant que guild les métiers de
l'éguille rassemble une quarantaine de
couturière professionnelle lancée
pendant le confinement
le collectif a distribué plus de 55000
blues dans trois départements dont les
yvelines avec mon plateau sébastien
turlure bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous votre initiative a les mêmes
nés avant de confinement puisque vous
avez créé en début d'année
un groupe facebook de dons et
d'entr'aide on va en parler dans un
instant et déjà une petite réaction sur
le sujet que l'on vient de voir est ce
que aussi vous de votre point de vue
associatif
vous avez trouvé pendant cette période
de confinement malgré on va dire la
coupure du lien social il s'est quand
même passé quelque chose oui oui s'est
passé quelque chose ça a été ça pas été
foule énorme mais il ya eu une hausse
pendant le confinement wii qui a été
remarquée sur le groupe
autant quand donc en personnes qui sont
venues adhérez vous avez constaté woods
des membres dans ce rôle mais légère
comment vous l'expliquez c'est le fait
d'être à distance on a besoin aussi de
lien de recréer ce lien social je pense
que ceux se ses ce genre de groupes
ressoude un peu leur permet de partager
d'échanger de faire de vraiment des
choses
solidaires on va la présenter dans un
instant dont est entré de coignières 78
310 vous me disiez d'ailleurs au
téléphone quand on préparait cet
entretien que ces mêmes depuis lé
déconfinement surtout vous observez un
plus de membres qui vous rejoignent tout
à fait pour vous donner un ordre d'idée
on a eu 250 membres depuis lé
déconfinement alors que depuis pendant
confinement il ya devant une petite
centaine qui sont venus quoi il y avait
peut-être la peur aussi de
de prendre les choses et du vivre du
coup du cornât virus et voila quoi donc
je pense que s'il ya beaucoup ça joue
beaucoup
s'il a envie de revenir vers vers les
autres après une période où on a été
on est resté chez soi donc je le disais
votre groupe dont et entraide coignières
a été créé en début d'année il permet à
vos membres de proposer des dons en tous
genres qui sont ensuite redistribués à
des familles dans le besoin
pourquoi vous avez lancé ce groupe je le
rappelle c'est en début d'année pourquoi
avoir eu cette envie l'envi en fait moi
j'étais comme tout le monde j'ai eues
j'étais sur des groupes qui existait
déjà auparavant
j'ai été déçu par par des groupes
c'est ce qui m'a donné l'envi en fait de
créer le mien on m'a dit que ça
marcherait pas g j ai été parce que moi
je suis quelqu'un qui est con j'ai une
idée en tête j'y vais j'y vais jusqu'au
bout
et voilà le résultat est là et à fond
que ça fonctionne très bien et les
personnes qui sont sur le groupe sont
très contents que je pense qu'on est sur
le secteur de coignières vous aviez
identifié des besoins des familles qui
avaient besoin de solidarité ou c'est
finalement parce que vous habitez à
coignières vous avez eu envie de lancer
ça autour de vous j'ai envie de vous
dire que les besoins et son besoin ils
sont présents partout quoi ya pas qu à
coignières c'est vrai que j'habite à
coignières donc j'ai créé mon groupe sur
coignières mais j'attends quand même sur
une zone géographique un peu faste un
peu large pour qu' il ya un maximum de
personne qui puisse en profiter
donc c'est des coignard rien mais aussi
les gens qui habitent autour de cette
commune de khwaja on disait des dons en
tout genre qu'est ce qu'on peut donner
quand même concrètes concrètement on
peut donner tout d'abord ce qui revient
souvent c'est les vêtements ça va du
bébé à l'adulte hommes femmes
il ya beaucoup ya de la vaisselle il ya
l'électro ménager un petit peu il ya
surtout du bibelot kizad il adore ça les
adore plus les bibelots que les
vêtements que parce que en fait quand il
me reste des des vêtements je vais je
vais leur donner à la croix rouge tout
simplement ça continue et dans le
circuit du solidaire de solidarité
comment ça fonctionne concrètement
rejoint le groupe
on propose une fois qu'on a on accède au
groupe que vous acceptez je suis un
groupe privé on peut à proposer les dons
de chacun est libre de proposer ce qu'il
veut ce qu'il veut plus et le publie les
gens qui sont sur le groupe qui sont
intéressés qui sont dans le besoin bon
c'est pas tout le temps le cas parce
qu'il ya toujours des personnes qui
n'ont pas spécialement besoin et on a
tous un petit besoin de toi sont je me
dis donc y publient et après les gens
prennent les échanges et conviennent
d'un rendez-vous et est depuis alors la
création on disait c'est en début
d'année c'est une centaine de familles
qui a pu être et les bonnes centaines
oui oui mais j'étais étonné par quand
j'ai exploité un peu les comptes
les contes les statistiques du groupe
j'ai vu qu'ils avaient comme
cinq cent dix membres qui étaient actifs
alors je sais pas ce qu'ils entendent
par côté actif
c'est peut-être venir voir ce qui se
passe sans interagir 690 en voilà au
jour d'aujourd'hui il ya six ans 90
membres pour une association qui a huit
mois je trouve une association un groupe
qui a été créé il ya huit mois je pense
que c'est pas trop mal mais justement se
noyer à vue s'est transformé en
association cet été l'élan se poursuit
voilà avec l'objectif d'être un peu plus
structuré rsa voilà mon désir ce serait
d'avoir un local pour pouvoir proposer
des choses plus plus de propositions de
ski informatique de l'aide à faire des
courriers faire des cv avoir un petit
point internet des choses comme ça sont
un peu plus élargie et plus dé change
quoi surtout parce que les gens je le
sens il aime bien échanger discuter puis
on en est où
concrètement là dans la recherche de ce
local ça il y a des il ya des touches
veut pour l'instant ces peluches des
boks parce que il n'y a pas trop de
disponibilité à par mois aux alentours
et locale rrb on cherche on cherche
voilà jusqu'à temps qu'on va trouver
elle peut être un noël des enfants qui
est organisée où il s'est maintenu
malgré le contexte ne sais pas bonne
question parce que en fait
déjà j'avais le roi 120 personnes dans
la salle j'ai eu un coup de fil il ya
peu du changement qui a de l'ajout de
règles limité à 30 personnes qui étaient
on m'a dit qu'un et là je viens
d'apprendre que c'est redescendu à 30
donc je l'aï appris comme tout le monde
donc maintenu j'espère qu'il va être
maintenue même si ces trente personnes
30 enfants ou 30 personnes
ça sera toujours ça que j'aurais pu
faire merci à sébastien turlure d'être
venu parler de cette initiative
en plateau bravo à vous le sit ins et
afficher les liens de la page facebook
pour toutes les informations un élan de
solidarité qui s'est créée aussi envers
les commerçants pendant le confinement
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a lancé sa page facebook sky
soutient ces commerçants un endroit pour
mettre en avant les bonnes initiatives
informer aussi des consommateurs pour
les aider à faire leurs courses on peut
d'ailleurs y retrouver une carte
interactive pour tout connaître savoir
tout ce qu'il ya autour de chez vous une
page lancée en mars est toujours active
aujourd'hui le groupe est public et
compte plus de 4200 membre associé à
l'école pour faire aussi face à la crise
des commerçants se sont alliées quatre
enseignes ont décidé de créer une
entraide inter commerçante alpes à xigua
vap et les restaurant la terrasse et
burger xxè leur objectif c'est de
communiquer et de trouver des solutions
pour pallier les difficultés de chacun à
l'interview express au micro de bixente
n'a rien senti steban
petit à petit on s'est vus on à échanger
sur les problématiques des commerçants
donc moi j'avais beaucoup à apprendre
puisque puisque je n'étais pas du tout
dans le domaine et ensuite est venu à
cette crise sanitaire ou là
notre comment dire solidarité s'est
renforcée justement pour faire face à
cette crise qui générait des problèmes
économiques
mettez moi mon nez dans la restauration
donc il peut m'arriver moi parce que
justement crise sanitaire j'ai une
employée qui est à temps partiel donc je
suis moins disponibles voilà j'ai pu de
crème fraîche j'appelle à m hind dehiba
portes de la crème fraîche
il a plu des fluides et sans des oeufs
des tomates voilà des matières premières
dont on a besoin
olga qui est conseiller municipal à la
mairie
son objectif c'est de nous accompagner
est ce cette micro associations de
commerçants c'est d'en faire quelque
chose
à l'ampleur de saint cyr avec l'ensemble
des commerçants de saint cyr
le confinement plus la crise économique
lui ont été fatales la start-up
versaillaise oui 3 a dû cesser son
activité la société créée en 2017 et est
spécialisé dans les locations de
trottinettes au travers de ces stations
nicolas landry laventure we trust s'est
arrêté au mois de juillet 2020 la
start-up yvelinoise a été contrainte de
déposer le bilan
engagé dans la location de trottinettes
we trust a lancé en 2019 la production
des premières stations destinées au
quartier de la défense
un investissement de 300 mille euros
problème
la société ne réussit pas à trouver
d'investisseurs nous avions un bilan
même s'il était négatif en termes de
trésorerie à fin décembre on avait
encore des fonds propres qui était assez
conséquente euros de fonds propres
on avait trouvé les marchés on avait
notamment un opérateur transports
publics étaient prêts à nous accompagner
nous aider dans l'implantation des
stations sur certaines villes plus un
groupe hôtelier plus de sociétés dans le
monde du bâtiment
donc on avait les on avait des
ouvertures qui est intéressant que des
négociations en cours
en mars 2020 ces négociations en cours
aurait permis de trouver des solutions
aux problèmes d'investissement
le colis de 19 est venu casser cette
dynamique en entraînant ensuite la fin
de l'entreprise lui trotte on a fait la
demande auprès des organismes d'état
donc pour obtenir un prêt garanti par
l'état puisque nos banques ont refusé de
les bonus se fait là ont refusé le pge
six et douze accompagnants
il y avait encore le prevail silence
mais qui était pas suffisant pour
pouvoir tenir le coup on devait
absolument aller chercher à peu près 200
250 millions euros pour pouvoir relancer
l'activité
garder les salariés cette société née à
saint quentin en yvelines en 2010 est
fondée par christophe bass et grégory
hanquez et pascal chanvin sur la suite
du projet et de l'idée laventure
pourrait se relancer mais le temps est à
la réflexion autour de la solution de
huy trotte dans l'actualité du jour une
soixantaine de personnes rassemblées ce
jeudi matin devant la cour d'appel de
versailles c'était à l'initiative de
plusieurs collectifs féministes pour
demain
et justice pour julie victimes de viol
présumée les explications d'eléonore si
nos caisses les faits remontent à 2009
trois pompiers de la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de paris sur la
vingtaine impliqué avait été mise en
examen pour viols sur mineurs en juillet
le juge a finalement décidé de
requalifier les faits en atteinte
sexuelle
c'est cette requalification que
plusieurs collectifs féministes ont
dénoncé jeudi 24 septembre devant la
cour d'appel de versailles
tout comme la relaxe des dix sept autres
pompiers ils sont venus également
soutenir julie la victime et corinne sa
mère on attend bien évidemment que les
viols soient reconnus comme des viols
comme des crimes
c'est le combat de julie c'est de faire
reconnaître ce qu'elle a subi
qui un préjudice énorme aujourd'hui elle
est extrêmement fragile elle était déjà
avant et ses pompiers le savait pendant
l'audience le procureur a annoncé qu'il
allait plaider pour le maintien de la
requalification en atteinte sexuelle ce
qui a provoqué la colère des militantes
féministes dont une partie a pénétré
dans l'enceinte de la cour d'appel
elles en sont ressortis quelques minutes
plus tard à la demande de la mère de
julie qui a accepté de s'exprimer à la
fin de l'audience
on est épuisés ce qu'on est restés
dehors c'était un peu frustrant mais
j'ai confiance dans nos avocats nantes
lui nous ont dit
j'ai un espoir parce que
toutes les femmes la juge est nouvelle
sur sur versailles
j'espère que enfin le dossier va être vu
pour ce qu'il est et non pas
parce que ce sont des pompiers parce que
tous sont des militaires voilà
juste il doit être en vue à gerland la
décision définitive sur cette
qualification sera rendu le 12 novembre
prochain
du jamais vu en dix ans les réserves de
sang continue de baisser elles ont
atteint le seuil de 82 mille poches
cette semaine alors qu'il en faudrait
cent mille pour avoir un niveau
suffisant malgré l'appel de
l'établissement français du sang les
dons ne remonte pas la crise sanitaire a
désorganisé les collectes est depuis le
confinement il n'ya plus par exemple de
dons organisée dans les entreprises et
dans les universités à lui le fs tire
donc la sonnette d'alarmé et appelle
tous les franciliens à donner leur sang
il faudrait dix mille dont chaque jour
pour répondre aux besoins des patients
et des points de collectes fixes et
mobiles existent dans toute
l'ile-de-france pour savoir où et
comment donner rendez vous aux liens qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran pour
refermer ce journal ils ont peut être
perturber vos repas en extérieur durant
les vacances d'été
et ça c'est encore plus grave ce sont
aussi de grands prédateurs de l'abeille
est un insecte ô combien important pour
notre biodiversité les guêpes et frelons
asiatiques sont de plus en plus nombreux
en ile de france et dans le département
leur nid doivent être traités par des
sociétés spécialisées
reportage à un joueur qu'on châtre johar
pontchartrain es2 célia agathe son go et
bixente mayence insisté ban à vous avez
plusieurs centaines voire même là en
parlant milliers d'individus dans le nid
presque 50 cm de diamètre c'est la
taille du nid de frelons repérer sur une
propriété de jouars pontchartrain
il nécessite une intervention rapide on
va injecter directement la poutre qui
est compressé dans mon dos le pirate
dans le petit trou qui est ici donc l
entrée du nid le produit utilisé le
pyrèthre végétal insecticides pleurer
maintenant dans la nature il avant les
occupants momentanément agressif je mets
des lunettes
l'ag des projections de venin
directement dans les yeux sur la visière
donc là surtout on laisse le nid en
place avec l'insecticide pendant 72
heures et s'il doit y avoir un retrait
ne se fera uniquement après 72 heures de
traitement dans un nid de cette taille
là on a plusieurs milliers d'individus
et le savoir car ni qui n'est pas
traitée à générer
douze et quatorze mille frelon est à peu
près 6 à 800 fondatrice pour l'année
prochaine on a la chance au niveau de la
région ile-de-france d'avoir un
organisme qui s'appelle la fredon et qui
a mis en place un protocole
d'intervention qui appose entre autres
de laisser les mis en place la société
dgf a reçu pendant l'été entre 80 à 120
demandes par jour
le confinement a permis à certains ni de
proliférer en toute tranquillité cela
est assez particulière pour plusieurs
facteurs déjà on a eu un hiver qui était
très propice au développement des
fondatrices un hiver qui était très doux
avec un printemps qui a suivi avec des
températures qui ont été régulières
c'est une saison un petit peu différent
des autres parce qu'effectivement on
augmenter notre volume d'interventions
qu'on est multipliée quasiment par deux
et demi par rapport à la saison dernière
il reste encore un mois avant la fin de
la saison des guettes les nids de
frelons peuvent persister plus longtemps
s'ils n'ont pas été traitées d'ici là
mais voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal dans un instant le 7-8 loisirs
afin de connaître notre sélection
d'idées de sorties à faire ce week-end
dans les yvelines belle soirée à tous
sur tv 78
[Musique]